so team why do you think that the study
of language is important to philosophy
you know he's fruitful way of
approaching this option although
studying language doesn't necessarily
tell you a huge amount about the
underlying nature of the world if if you
make mistakes about everything about
language you are liable to be to be led
into extremely bad metaphysics and even
even if a good philosophy of language
can't give you good metaphysics bad
philosophy of language can give you bad
metaphysics and and I think and I think
people because of mistakes that they
were making in the fallacy of language
which I saw work corrected where we're
arriving at all sorts of conclusions
about how they thought that there was
some kind of basic logical problem about
the ideas that things could have their
own essential nature which was just made
them what the thing that they were and
and they were ruling out a lot of
metaphysical options on the basis of
misunderstandings of language people
talk a lot about the the linguistic turn
in in philosophy and and that for a long
time I think people were treating this
as some kind of completely irreversible
turn in philosophy by which somehow
philosophy Oh fundamentally had to do
with with language and and words it's
quite understandable why people would
think something like like that because
what one of their sort of central
methodological problems for philosophy
are after the the Scientific Revolution
was how much room that that the
development of Natural Science left for
philosophy to tell us anything about the
the world and I think so one I sort of
kind of retreat that the people
attracted people was the idea well you
know in when we're doing philosophy
we're not really studying how the the
world is we're just study you know
thinking
about either how we do talk about it or
what might be a better way of talking
about it and so on and just as it were
clarifying language or something like
like that and I mean that was different
versions of that idea we're very
influential but I think it's becoming
clearer that that was really a 20th
century idea which by the end of the
20th century was really actually on the
way out and it doesn't mean that you can
do philosophy without paying attention
to language because that's where
philosophies done in language and you
know we've got to understand how our
instruments work in order to use them
properly I mean if you're an astronomer
you can't say look I mean I'm interested
in the what's going on and in space I'd
know I'm not interested in telescopes so
I don't and I'm not gonna spend any time
worrying about how my telescope works I
mean that would be a very naive attitude
for an astronomer and it's a it's a
naive attitude for a philosopher to take
the same view of language that we don't
need to borrow the right language we'll
just use it to talk about the the world
the role of language and philosophy is
more like that than like the idea that
somehow there's something very specially
linguistic about philosophical questions
when philosophers are interested in time
people tried to interpret that as really
that's just an interest in in the
language that we used to talk about time
or something like that but I think it's
become clearer actually that a lot of
the interesting philosophical questions
are about time itself and not just about
the language that we use about it but if
we if we misunderstand the language that
we used to talk about time then we're
probably going to reason very very badly
about about time itself so we do have to
be kind of self conscious about a use of
language but without as we're making
that anything like the the subject
matter of philosophy first time how we
should think about it is a special
problem since Einstein and all that has
really changed
conception of which the natural
conception is suggest there is an
objective right you know slow things are
present fast and so on and of course the
picture has gotten very different and
this is some case where things outside
philosophy have affected the
philosophical problems I was gonna call
important to you is that you know your
views are grounded in common sense it's
very yeah I I always think the common
sense for you well here I just meant
something where maybe physics is
undermined what would have been
otherwise the natural common-sense food
but other than things like that I think
one should preserve gee Bohr who was
famous in the 20th century for
advocating that the common sense view of
the things should be preserved as much
as possible such common sense the
knowledge or something like that is that
there is a glass of water in front of me
or whatever or there are tables and
chairs and people and so on
those are more certain than any
philosophical theory and people who
think that philosophical theory comes
first are wrong right may be one thing
that's worth saying about the this
example of time and special relativity
where it seems in some sense the similar
to what counts as present depends on
what frame of reference you have I think
a lot of people you know wonder whether
there's any room left for philosophy to
do anything about a subject like time
because they think it could shouldn't we
just leave that to the physicists you've
got to take a kind of what the
physicists have discovered and and you
know it would not be sensible to try to
talk about the nature of time without
without taking special relativity into
account but the expertise of the
physicists does not automatically extend
- to working out what the implications
are for for for metaphysics for what
this tells us in less formal terms about
the about the nature of the the world
and in particular as it were just how
much of common sense is or isn't
undermined by by the science I think
it's I mean that's something that
philosophers have their own distinctive
skills in and thinking about not that
it's at all easy the good way of
dramatizing a piece of science is by
presenting it as having refuted some
piece of common sense and I mean that's
maybe a good way of getting grant money
but it it's often when you look at the
site you see it doesn't have as much of
an effect in undermining common sense
may not leave common sense exactly where
it was but but it may not be as big as
disruptive of common sense as you know
that scientists hyping their own
discoveries like to pretend right I
entirely agree yeah an important
distinction that you extract cinnamon in
necessities between the metaphysical and
epistemological and you try to separate
the notions and I mean your analysis of
names your work on language led you to
that so it's hard to say something
without telling people to read the book
but a lot of a lot of and and of course
this is a general audience anyway but
look I came to conclude that a lot of
the confusions that well that we're
topping in say in the coining era that I
was talking about came from confusing
two different things what is what do we
know a priori that is in the absence of
any way much experimental knowledge or
anything right or what well there's also
what we know
certain which is a different issue
really because a mathematical
calculation may be a four all right but
it isn't one certainly you may have made
a mistake in the calculation anyway
those are epistemic notions notions
about knowledge okay but then according
to me anyway what I concluded and Hilary
Putnam had in some respects some similar
views about this some sorts of
statements about necessary properties of
particular things like if this table was
made of one substance the very same
table couldn't have been made of another
one right but that it's made of this
substance rather than of that one it's
not something you necessarily know but
you find out so people thought that
meant it wasn't necessary but I think
that that's confusing an epistemological
with what I call a metaphysical notion
or really a notion about what might have
been not what may or may not be you know
certain right and I wouldn't think any
counter factual situation that doesn't
contain this very substance which is h2o
would contain water right though we
don't know without scientific
investigation what water consists in
right
you